I was bit surprised that such strong
messages are sent through social
networks because this is actually the
matter and the keys to take a phone and
to call your partners all over the world
do you think it's really rude do you
still think that this world that this
word is existing in our world I'm I
really doubt it's gone beyond that in
terms of the relationship between Russia
in the United States way beyond that
you know I don't think we should mark
the words saying this word is rude and
this is a polite word because we have
Syria on board I mean with all these
troubles happening to the to the people
and children and what we actually want
and I'm hundred percent sure that
American people British people French
people I mean common people they really
want peace for this for this country not
because we are a great fans of damask or
we're great fans of Syria itself not B
not because only of that but because we
we solve for many years what happened
with refugees and people who are trying
to leave their homes and trying to move
for Europe for example this is not only
the problem of Middle East and North
Africa this is also the whole world's
probably not probably the problem of
United States of America because they
are not accepting refugees from there
not in its quantities I hate to use
quantity with the world people but we
are realist unfortunately but it's the
problem for example of Italy
it's a problem of France Germany etc etc
so let us more think about what is going
on the ground so you think that the
Russian role should be more appreciated
by the West and in particular Europe and
the European Union appreciation it's not
what we're really focused on well I use
that just because Dom drumming his
latest tweet asked to be thanked he said
where is the thank you America for for
its role well for it defeating Isis he
said I think I actually I think that he
was addressing to his people don't you
think so when he was asking for
appreciation I thought that he asked
Americans to appreciate what he did to
Syria and country counter-terrorist I
think actually that people in Iraq is
still thinking United States America was
for what they were doing and what they
done to their country and so we hope
that Syria will have better future
unfortunately it's really involved in
war it's really involved in
counterterrorism and we really think
that we do not need any sort of
appreciation of what we are doing on the
ground what we need we need cooperation
similar words but a little bit okay but
let's talk about the imminence of a
strike Donald Trump has said it might
not happen now it might not happen soon
but still giving the sense that it is
going to happen is that the assessment
of the Russian Federation that the
United States and its allies will launch
some form of military operation pretty
soon in Syria in 2015 President of
Russia during his statements in in New
York UN headquarter asked for world
cooperation on Syria on combating
terrorists for this year's I mean about
three years past our proposal is still
on the table and we actually are looking
forward closer cooperation with other
countries on Syria we really wanted and
we really needed but it doesn't seem to
be happening that's the point the
missiles are coming according to the
president of the United States mainly
clarify please don't ask me about what
US president is doing please say I was
asking you about the the assessment of
the Russian Federation I mean and and
indeed the response this is very
important the response of the Russian
Federation should missiles be launched
should protect its people on the ground
of course Russia should protect its
people on their own what about the
incoming missiles we have this from the
ambassador to Lebanon that they would be
shot down in the basis from which they
come attacked
I would have stress one more time and
that was the idea of our ambassador in
Lebanon as well that Russia will protect
its people on the ground
this is Obus which is this this is the
task for each and every country in the
world to protect the citizens on the
ground so our people our soldiers there
they're not for conquering I don't know
conquering Syrian people they are for
protecting Syrian people they came to
Syria upon the proposal and invitation
of Syrian people and just you can go to
Syria you can you can just see with your
own eyes how Syrian people really
appreciate Russian presence on the
ground so Russia will protect its own
people
so if Russia lives are lost if Russian
blood is spilt we'll American blood be
spilled I really don't want to even
think about this because you know I just
want to remind you and myself and
everybody who will watch this this
interview that we're living in 2018 we
have all sort of communication including
Twitter and we can resolve all the
questions like that just picking up the
phone
just sending messages and I think that
this is the case which which should be
resolved through the communication but
not through force well I know you don't
speak for the the president the
presidential office but you're saying
it's not too late for the two presidents
to talk to each other I just answered
this question that's in another way in
other words yes I get it I mean because
I was reading just yesterday that the
last leader of the Soviet Union Mikhail
Gorbachev no less the the Nobel Peace
Prize winner saying that it is
imperative that these two presidents
must meet that a summit must take places
as he held with President Reagan and
President George HW Bush that this is
the way to sort it out that is his
opinion
would you endorse that ever so slightly
uh I'm a representative of ministry
Foreign Affairs
I cannot endorse or not endorse such
things as a person in my personal
capacity I can say that the only thing I
want as a mother as a wife as a just a
citizen of my country and actually a
citizen of the world because I have lots
of friends all over the world all I want
is peace peaceful for both for Syrian
people for others and especially I want
peaceful my country and I have I need
because I really spent several years in
the United States I have lots of friends
and colleagues there I need i
religiously need good relationship in
the United States I cannot understand
why Americans I mean American
politicians congressmen some people in
administration are still blind to what
we are trying to propose them we're
trying to propose cultivation normal
corporation on the platform of you and
chatter is it so difficult to understand
that Russia is not for war but for peace
and good captivation and good
relationship with the whole world is it
so impossible just to take this as as it
is you said earlier that Russia holds no
candle that doesn't necessarily support
all of President Assad's policies or
indeed his methods that's true Russia
doesn't necessarily support President
Assad in his message yes all his
policies absol and of course he along
with the the oversight of Russia
apparently gave up all his chemical
weapons supplies in 2013 would you
accept that perhaps before that he may
well have gassed his own people you know
I'm not an advocate for a Syria and
especially for mr. Assad actually before
chemical design
we add before even that mr. asset was
the best friend not at Moscow but of
London and Washington that was mr. Kerry
when he was representing Senate yes he
was Senate again senator Kenney yes when
before he was nominated even before he
was nominated as the Secretary of State
he was he was in a very good and very
friendly relationship with mr. awesome
mr. Assad spent his life in Great
Britain he was much for the West but not
for Russia and now you're asking me to
advocate mr. asset no he's not our guy
he's much more your guy we are in Syria
just to stop terrorism and stop
spreading ISIL and other terrorist
organization because we are much closer
to Syria when for example United States
and we were really focused on this task
not let terrorists to go from Syria and
the region to Russia because we were we
were through this problem for many years
and 90s you can recall Northern Caucasus
and Chechnya and we were through
combating terrorism in our country and
we did not want to let them come again
okay so you accept that Assad is not a
good guy you are no advocate for Assad
yet you don't accept that he's capable
of using chemical weapons against his
own people you know I think good guys in
the church okay but this specific attack
which is led us to the situation we're
in it's the Russian position that it
wasn't an attack that it has been fired
let us be absolutely clear for that
particular case that happened a couple
of days ago we we are we are hundred
percent sure that that was a clear
provocation for example white helmets we
are absolutely sure were involved in
this provocation
we have how can you prove that you know
I can ask you the same question how can
you prove that asset is involved but we
never never for this years were answered
this question nobody give us any sort of
information to prove that the masks was
involved in the situation we have our
materials on the ground we we just take
and we had and we made an analytic
monitoring of all the statements which
were made by white helmets and all the
for example terrorist organizations on
the ground and we understood that
they're really pretty much together and
they're just there
what they're doing it's it's a quite
sort of cooperation so sorry just to be
clear here are you saying that either it
wasn't a sad that did the chemical
weapons attack or that there was no
chemical weapons attack altogether we
know for sure that the Syrian government
didn't we absolutely sure because our
experts were involved sure that Syrian
government was not involved in any sort
of attacks including chemical weapons
but was that chemical well I could have
been carried out by a third party but
there is a probability of using chemical
materials for example on the ground and
we have our information that for example
terrorist and extremist organizations
are involved in this and we have
suspicions which are really close to be
truth that white helmets are always also
involved but but what the Russian
military is is a sense that there was no
chemical weapons to tackle together and
that these scenes were faked
they were acted exactly together exactly
and what we need to just to prove what
that was was it just a provocation to be
shown as a chemical attack or they were
any sort of chemical material
what we propose is to send the
representatives of organization of
prohibition of chemical weapons to the
ground and to make it as quick as
possible because last time the previous
time when a similar thing happened you
know that the experts were not on the
ground and what the information they
gather it was not from Syria I mean they
were not taken or gathering it
themselves they just received some sort
of information through NGOs and isn't
this isn't this the opportunity now to
let them in with Russian forces control
the area we understand legislation
worried by what what we proposed and
when in the world we made a statement
and today I said it one more time that
we can propose our facilities and our
help and assistance for the experts
international experts to come to Syria
to take the evidence and we understand
that the mosque also can provide such an
assistant who are you inventing the
experts and representatives of
international organizations which are
prohibition of chemical you yes and the
World Health Organization want to come
in as well they can do together but of
course the first place is for
organization for prohibition of chemical
weapons because they are they should
make their expertise first of all and
the same moment the same moment when we
proposed for expert to come to Syria the
same moment Washington made statements
of using a force so if the force will be
used and the smart missiles will will be
sent to Syria how can the experts get
any sort of evidence on the ground this
is really impossible she's saying hold
off and allow the evidence to come out
but on that issue of missiles and we
must move on i I know two discreet bolts
but on that issue of missiles I've been
talking to former senior military Figg
is in the Russian Federation who are
drawing parallels with a situation at
the moment in the Russian missile crisis
and saying that we are not that far away
they believe if certain circumstances
occur from a nuclear war I really I just
even don't want to talk about this thing
just don't let me even think about this
you know I just want to remind you one
more time
it's 2018 it's not you know the middle
of 20th century we are at the beginning
at the first quarter of 21st century you
know we're human being we can talk if
you and me can talk why people who are
in charge of our security and
international peace can not talk this is
my question so this is your message is
it your message to the West to the UK to
the United States saying you're not
talking to us our first message let's be
constructive and let's talk about how we
can resolve crises but not increase
crisis and just lastly on this issue if
it goes wrong if the strikes occur if
Russians are killed or injured in the
strikes stop just well start well this
is a possibility that the world is
considering and just on that and in the
and the the threat that Russia will
retaliate attack the missiles attack
attack the basis well the one question
is of the basis from which the missiles
come if they are attacked by Russia they
presumably would also include UK bases
because it looks like that the UK will
be part of the coalition we are not
asking this question UK or you as
authorities it's not the question for
Russia Russia is not behaving
aggressively Russia in Syria is upon the
invitation of Syrian people you know
this is our relationship with Syria we
are not threatening anybody of using
threat or using force or smart missiles
you know we are trying to help Syrian
people to reconstruct their life and
your question should be addressed to
okay in the United States on to the
screep house you must be delighted about
the recovery of Ullaeus creeped out oh
yes the only thing that we actually want
to be sure that this is for real because
for that particular moment we have just
zero information from official London
about what is going on with her our
ambassador in London mr. jacqueline
Cassell dozens of diplomatic notes to
the Foreign Office and he was answered
once or twice one diplomatic note which
he was he received in response said that
she's better she's feeling better and
this is it and nothing more and this
statement which were attributed to
julius [ __ ] was published on the
website of Scotland Yard it was we hope
that this is her statement but we do not
have any proof that this is her words
and actually she's not isolated and
especially that she's not as elated from
the media because we have no
understanding does she have any access
to for example internet used to TV
according to the statement it's it's
rather strange the dijo text is rather
strange it's not actually how young
girls are communicating with the world
these days according to this statement
what we can feel that probably she's
really isolated and she's really
isolated from using internet and other
media things and this is brought it's
very strange but do you think she's
actually been abducted as the Russian
embassy said in London abducted we we
have such suspicions we have such a
feeling yes held against her will
probably yes because we you know the the
whole issue it's a mystery we do not
have any sort of official information
what has what happened in Salisbury how
many people were involved in this I
don't know
or in the situation in this crime we
even don't know what that was where it
happened in the house on the street on
the bench in the bar in the restaurant
in the shopping center we just have the
quotation of British official visual
Britain British official which are
presenting on the web in the media and
nothing else no official information we
want to go step by step and understand
what happened that particular day what
chemical materials or weapon was used
how it was used how many people was
using it against Russian citizen well
I'm sure this is sure there's a lot of
questions the British investigating
authorities want to know that and that's
why there are there are gaps as an
investor I do know why they're hiding
all these things I think they already
know what happened to this creep pause
the the very day of the accident you
don't I'm sorry how can the the accuse
Russia without even that basic
information of course they should know
of course they should know I know that
Great Britain is spread is is full of
cameras I don't know how they will you
call them CCTV clothes yeah television
cameras yes something like that which is
actually a sort of providing security in
the country so where are the materials
from these cameras why they are so
secret that nobody can present them to
the audience indeed all legitimate value
questions that we've been asking in the
media as well we were told about
opinions what about the cell phone
communication the scree Paul his
daughter and other people what about
what about the house now what we saw in
the media that they won't want to
destroy the house but this is actually
the main evidence in this case but they
want to destroy the house but I'm sure
in any police investigation in
whatever country in whatever democracy
the investigation continues and the
evidence is being gathered and they
don't tell you about the evidence as
they got they exclude one thing
accusations accusations should be made
after investigation but not before but
they were made just the very beginning
of this investigation I'm not sure that
investigation has already started but
but the accusation the concrete
accusation precise accusations were
already made and another thing the
punishment which already happened
they already punished us sending back
our diplomats that was punishment so
please tell me how accusation and
punishment can be before the
investigation but not after well I think
you know the answer to that because the
agent used was identified as a form of
Nava choc which apparently only the
Russian Federation manufactured back at
me in a moment but but you asked you
asked you know the substance having not
been identified but you know yourself we
had the organization for the prohibition
of chemical weapons bring out its report
today and I heard you saying I also have
only read there the summary of it but
it's very clear and I'll put my glasses
on to read it when it talks about the
biomechanical samples collected by the
OPCW they confirm the findings of the UK
relating to the identity of the toxic
chemical that was used in Salisbury I it
was no recharge and they say it was high
purity even if it's not a choc you know
how many countries were developing
another choc have you idea about that
more than 20 about 20 about 20 we
announced our information on several
countries and even when we have no
information about this case we asked the
old ambassadors which accredited in
Moscow to come to Ministry to foreign
affairs just to share our information
about Navi talk about all the chemical
aspects of this case and to share this
information
with them about 20 countries were
possibilities to develop this chemical
material can you understand it while
Russia why they pointed out Russia where
Russia is always on their mind well you
put also pointed out amongst that 20
countries you say could have produced an
overshot type weapon you include the
United Kingdom amongst those countries
don't you why not
because Porton Down Laboratory is why
not the greatest and the these
scientists who are working there they're
really well known all over the world
and actually just just I know that this
is just the part of not probably a part
it's it's just an idea but this is it
says this is it this is obvious that
Salisbury is too close to put him down
not to Moscow it was this is this is
this the Russian theory that it was it
was I mean to answer your question they
put me why would this happen that the UK
have done this to to push Russia into a
corner to demonize Russia the thing is
that Boris Johnson's accused Russia in
providing twenty-ninth theories on what
happens in Salisbury come on we have no
theories at all all we had and how we
have questions where I have we have
questions to ask and we ask them and we
received nothing officially from London
as answers on our questions so we have
no theories at all what we understand
that that is a provocation because
something happened and in this something
Russia was accused that is a classical
provocation this is one thing and
another thing that London and for us
it's also obvious is faking so much
so-called news and materials based on
sources and trying to present so many
theories that for us it's
all this propaganda thing but you know
some people would say is it's your
ability to identify fake news and
sourcing misinformation your ability to
identify that is because Russia has been
doing it so for so long itself and it's
very good at it can you show me one
example I'm not carrying examples of
them saying people say this people
should not say something without without
evidence you know the thing is that you
know control at Agatha Christie they are
from from England and I was in my
childhood I was reading all these
stories and all these books with great
pleasure and I think that lots of
British people are really in love with
this literature what is the big
difference between the literature and
how its described step by step the
investigation and what is going on now
in Great Britain when every and each
representative of official governmental
structure is giving very contradiction
and contradicted information well we
could quote Christian Conan Doyle at
each other for a long time including the
the Conan Doyle line that if you
discount all the other possibilities in
the one you're left with however
improbable is the only one then that is
the answer I just wanted what does the
yes Kapoor who was quoted by Boris
Johnson so does the yes key in his one
of his greatest book he used English
proverb
let me quote it from a hundred rabbits
you cannot make a horse and hundred
suspicions don't make it proof I think
this is the words to describe the whole
situation we actually can talk we can be
suspicious we can accuse each other but
what we really want and what Russia
proposed is to start joint investigation
or to let our expert to come to Great
Britain to be in
this investigation or to somehow give us
provide us with materials about this
case and we refused and we don't know
why probably because this case is so
much politicized well there are some in
the British political world who perhaps
more towards your view on questions to
be asked and I'm thinking of the leader
of the Opposition Jeremy Corbyn who may
in the next election become Prime
Minister is his take on this the idea
that they're more questions need to be
asked and and indeed when it comes to
Syria that no action should take place
without it I'm not I don't think that
he's advocating Russia I think that he's
much more about question he's very
pragmatic and he's asking questions
which are Russia is asking and
journalists and the media are asking
because actually we want to know what
happened and why we're refused of
providing us this information
so oh he is talking about it's just a
pragmatic thing because if you are
accusing a whole state in doing such
things you should give any sort you know
of playing cards you should put some
cards on the table what do you have
where you're just have a poker face okay
and lastly yeah back to the the
individuals the main individuals
involved in this the discreet balance is
it your hope and one hopes that Ullaeus
creeper will watch this interview is it
your hope that you'll escape I will
return to the motherland will return to
Russia to decide no no this is
absolutely up to her to decide this is
her decision where to live before that
before this situation he used she used
to live in Russia and she was visiting
her father yes I never met her I have no
idea about you'll escape all before
something happened in Salisbury but as I
understand that it was rather okay for
her to live in Russia and to visit her
father but it's absolutely up to any
Russian citizen where to live what
place to live and what place to choose
for living it's according our
constitution so it's nobody can tell me
or somebody else where where should we
we can use any place on the planet to
live and still be the Russian citizen
with which is a very smart thing
actually so all I hope and of course I
wanted wish you'll escape all all the
health and I hope that one day we know
the truth because we need we in Russia
need know the truth because we were it
accused each and every person in Russia
wanna know truth this is you know this
is something which actually you know I
received so many letters through emails
through fax even just just ordinary just
traditional letters or is if so many of
them just saying it's it's unbelievable
why they accusing us in what we were not
doing and without any sort of evidence
showing nothing and just just common
Russian people sending letters saying
why tell them to provide us any sort of
materials we want to know it's so it's
so unfair it's cetera et cetera and just
lastly you wished Yulia scree pal the
best of health presumably that doesn't
apply to say okay well well he's a
traitor is big now he was but he was
always accused in these things and he
was put in jail and he is not he is not
actually according to the law he is not
a prisoner he is just an ordinary person
you know it's a very tricky thing when
you ask me can you wish for example
scrape our family health and of course I
do
and I want but another thing I want to
really know what is going on with them
what is happening to them right now and
what happened to them amongst the girl
because probably probably we
we still don't have this information
probably they are good and they were
good we understand that it's a huge
provocation which was which were
organized or used by London we still
don't have information or any sort of
evidence to say that was done by London
on purpose no but we obviously see that
London is using this provocation in
their interest and this is very bad it's
very bad not only for Russia but for the
whole world because each and every
country is watching how London is trying
to - I don't know - manipulate the
because of people's opinion I noticed in
your press briefing that more of it was
spent discussing the screep our case is
this because I am I wrong here is this
because the expulsion 'z have affected
Russia the sanctions the new sanctions
are hurting Russia we've seen the ruble
fall we've seen big Russian companies
crashing on stock markets are they
hurting come on let's be honest all the
sanctions happens not because of
scruples just because of anti Russian
campaign which is going on for years
against Russia why we spend so many time
discussing is [ __ ] kiss because it's
a huge minute mystery and nobody in the
world can understand what is going on
and we know we were accused in a very
dangerous things in a very bad things
and first of all we want to know the
truth secondly we just want to say that
it's a huge provocation and the third
thing we we we hope that someday the
troop will the truth will appear
probably will your help I don't know
maria vladimirovna we
appreciate you give me a so much time
thank you very much indeed thank you